[Music]
commonsense is useful for certain things
and of course from an evolutionary
perspective common sense arose to stop
us from eaten by lions on the savanna
but not to understand quantum mechanics
there's no sense in which our brains the
early evolution of our brains needed to
know anything about quantum mechanics or
relativity and what's amazing is that
nevertheless those brains that arose to
solve human problems on everyday scales
have allowed us to explore the universal
scales that are quite different and
scales were where everything that we
think is sensible goes away on quantum
mechanical scales where particles going
to be doing many things at the same time
or when you're moving very fast and your
perception of time can change compared
to mine and what we've learned of course
using those principles going beyond
common sense is that the universe our
myopic views of the universe are just
that they're myopic that the universe at
its fundamental skills look quite
different and in fact I began my new
book with the one of my favorite
allegories Plato's allegory allegory of
the cave where he likens our existence
to people trapped in a cave being forced
to look at the shadows of reality from
the light cast behind them on a wall and
he said the job of the scientist
essentially is to interpret those
shadows to understand the reality
underneath and when we look at the
universe around us we're seeing the
shadows of reality and what we've been
able to do is peer underneath to
discover the real world which is really
quite different and just as for those
individuals sitting there common sense
would tell them that the world is
two-dimensional because all they see is
the projection of reality we for us our
common sense tells us oh the world is
three-dimensional but we've learned in
fact that the universe isn't it's at
least four dimensional there are three
dimensions of space and one dimension of
time that are tied together yielding a
reality at its basis which is really
quite different from that which we
experience that's just one example of
the many ways we've been able to dive
down underneath this fabric that she
building the real world underneath and
the fabric is what perhaps our common
sense is based to understand and what's
underneath it's not too surprising that
it doesn't seem sensible because it
describes realms of the universe that we
did literally did not evolve to
originally understand and as I say it's
a it's an amazingly fortuitous accident
that our brains evolved so we could
understand those regions as well the
question arises naturally once we
understand at a fundamental level that
the universe looks quite different than
we perceive it to be whether what we're
now discovering is truly fundamental or
whether we died down deeper the
universal look different still Richard
Fineman argued that way he basically
said is the universe will we have a
theory of everything or is universe like
an onion and you peel back one layer and
there's another layer and it's it's an
infinite number of layers of onions or
Turtles all the way down depending upon
how you want to describe it the answer
is we don't know we don't know if
there's an ultimate theory of everything
but it really doesn't matter in many
ways what we want to understand that the
universe we want to understand the
universe better today than we did
yesterday we want to expand our
understanding and that's what we try and
do and science often works by baby steps
we one of the things I described in my
book is a long series of baby steps that
took us to where we are now from our
understanding the universe on the scales
that we we see in this room to the
fundamental scales it there were many
steps that took us there and the process
is exciting and every new step of
discovery is exciting and every time you
make a new discovery there are more
questions than there are answers and so
there's guaranteed guaranteed job
security it seems to me for scientists
and I don't have any great expectations
there is a theory of everything or a
need to know that theory to me the
questioning and the search is as
exciting in some sense as the answers
you